un acte terroriste c'est l'appellation
retenue contre cet homme qui devait
fêter demain 30 mai ses 22 ans
interpellé ce matin à La Verrière
Alexandre a reconnu l'agression d'un
militaire samedi dernier il n'habitait
pas cette commune il s'y étaitug réfugié
il se revendique d'un islam radical les
dernières précisions avec ce sujet de la
rédaction maintenant aujourd'hui où
qu'on aille on n'est pas rassuré dans le
métro partout donc voilà ça m'étonne pas
mais quand on a des enfants ouais
maintenant on fait super attention on
ferme les portes on fait voilà on fait
super attention le choc à la verrière
après l'arrestation ce mercredi matin de
cet homme de 22 ans Alexandre dosi
suspecté d'être l'agresseur au cutteur
d'un militaire à la défense le 25 mai
placé en garde à vue il a rapidement
reconnu les faits mais l'enquête ne fait
que commencer le parquet et la police
judiciaire ont considéré que cet homme
était suffisamment dangereux à la fois
pour le placer sous l'autorité pour
placer cette enquête sous l'autorité du
parquet antiterroriste et pour mener euh
une action qui a conduit à son
arrestation à son interpellation ce
matin c'est grâce à ces images provenant
d'une caméra de surveillance mais aussi
à des traces d'ADN retrouvé sur une
bouteille d'eau oubliée que son
arrestation a été rendue possible aux
alentours de 6h du matin l'homme s'était
installé depuis quelques mois à La
Verrière dans le quartier du Bois de
l'étan originaire du Péré en Yveline
c'est un désaccord avec sa famille sur
sa conversion à un islam radical qui
l'aurait poussé à quitter le domicile
même les gens du quartier il le trouvé
un peu bizarre parce qu'il était un peu
des fois on le voyait à la mosquée
mais d'un autre côté il était il buvait
un peu d'alcool donc il cherchait je
pense que c'était c'est il faut pas
faire l'amalgame c'était pas un bon
musulman c'était pas un vrai musulman
moi je connais un peu les mosquées du
coin il y a pas de personne qui est en
doctrine je pense que c'était vraiment
une personne isolée c'est un fait isolé
et cette personne là se cherchait et
elle a fait ça peut-être pour par
rapport au au fait de Londres il voulait
faire une concurrence j'en ai pas la
moindre idée cherche d' explication mais
seul lui pour pour va la donner quoi
l'association des musulmans de la
verrière et le maire disent rejeter avec
force et fermeté les agissements de
celui qui aujourd'hui devra répondre
d'actes de terrorisme et qui était
jusque-là connu des services de police
pour plusieurs vols donc on va
communiquer on va essayer de de de
mettre bien la distance nécessaire entre
l'événement et la ville parce qu'il y a
une vraie distance entre l'événement et
la ville et on va on va rassurer notre
population on va rassurer les communauté
pour leur dire que nous continuons notre
travail d'accompagnement de soutien et
que tous ensemble nous nous démarquons
évidemment de ce type d'actes qui n'ont
pas lieu d'être dans notre commune comme
sur notre territoire le militaire blessé
au coup a retrouvé sa famille depuis
lundi avec une incapacité totale de
travail de 10
jours autre réaction pour conclure
concernant toujours la stigmatisation
éventuelle d'une communauté et d'une
ville celle de Jean-Philippe met le
député PS de la 11e circonscription des
ivelines qui comporte justement cette
ville de La Verrière il répondait aux
questions de Claire Cambier juste avant
de rejoindre l'assemblée
nationaleut une fois de plus évidemment
ne jamais faire d'amalgame quoi euh
entre entre des des personnes qui euh
qui ont de tels actes qui commettent de
tels actes mais ça bon il a encore une
enquête qui doit être diligentée mais
entre les personnes qui peuvent
commettre de tels actes et puis et puis
des croyants qui qui n'ont rien à voir
évidemment avec avec de tels agissements
quoi la communauté de laav
re hab
verre pas être
stigtis